the Texas family of five was among those
killed in a small plane crash in Canada
this morning investigators are still
trying to determine what caused the
plane to go down it happened in a
heavily wooded area near Kingston
Ontario Kris Van Cleave has more on the
investigation Canadian investigators are
working to identify the seven people on
board the six seat Piper Cherokee that
crashed Wednesday and pieced together
why the 54 year old single-engine plane
went down it was a very steep impact so
significantly steep and substantive
aircraft was destroyed the planes owner
auto back a block you loved was believed
to be flying along with his wife three
children ages 3 to 15 and two family
friends newlyweds from Toronto he bought
the plane to share his love of flying
with his family my whole family and put
my camping gear right here investigators
say they were flying between Toronto and
Quebec City when they attempted to land
in Kingston Ontario around 5:00 p.m. the
crash site is in line with the airport's
runway the ax block u loves neighbors in
Missouri City Texas describe the family
as friendly this is something you never
when I hear especially you know a family
like this
good family a block you loved earned his
pilot's license in 2018 and it only
recently bought the plane Canadian
authorities have yet to identify any of
the dead investigators say the plane was
in touch with the Kingston Airport
before the crash and came down about 3
miles short of the runway the Canadian
equivalent of our NTSB will lead the
accident investigation for CBS this
morning Saturday Kris Van Cleave
Washington